6 25 on your monday morning what's
driving me crazy how about an update on
the old nightmare on nellis drivers at
one of the busier intersections on the
valley seaside did you survive the
latest installment of the nightmare on
ellis now to be clear the nevada
department of transportation's official
name for the project is nellis boulevard
reconstruction most of the time it is
not a nightmare but when east-west
travel on bonanza is completely shut
down at nellis when nellis is down to
one lane in each direction of bonanza
for upwards of an entire weekend well
that's pretty tough that's just what
happened starting after eight last
friday night looks like they do have
that closed up or wrapped up now they
did that before sundown last night now
the overall aim repaving 10 miles of now
is from tropicana on the south up to
craig on the north it's easier to
understand when ndot breaks it down into
three phases first of which that was the
stretch from trop up to sahara we're in
phase two now taking care of nellis from
sahara up to owens phase three will take
the project all the way up to craig road
pedestrian safety features school zone
upgrades and lighting improvements all
part of that big picture we got a link
to ndot's page on the project in the
online version of this and all of our
stories at eightnewsnow.com click
traffic than driving you crazy buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone something's driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com